you would
gentlemen we're live gentlemen and a
lady
david please watch your language oh my
gosh you know once you get this voice of
god you start thinking like you can you
know say whatever you want to say but
anyways today today's guest is a special
guest we got governor ron desantis's
press secretary christina pusha here
with us thank you for making the time
for being here and thank you so much for
having me here yeah so i you know i was
i was uh
you know we have a lot of conversations
with different people and they talk
about who's going to be running for 2024
and obviously
ron desantis is in the conversation all
the time everyone's talking about it but
uh there's there's also this the poll
came out from you from cnn the guy that
was doing the poll saying
eight out of ten voters don't know who
ron the saying no no who he is they know
who he is but eleven percent was
him for voting 54 percent was trump with
the leader so many pack had it yeah i
think 21 to santa's 55 for trump so we
would like to take a different route
today with your help to get the audience
to learn a little bit more
about ron desantis
we are here because of the great job
he's done for the great state of florida
uh when we were living in texas he was
living in miami he moved to texas to be
with us for a year and a half he lived
right by addison beach which it doesn't
exist but you know to him
his nightlife was south beach and then
addison beach madison beach fantastic
for those people that are from madison
you know where addison beach is right by
uh your house was your place for this
house great fantastic place uh but we
moved from there to florida and we've
loved it a lot of it has to do with
obviously what governor desantis does we
were looking between l.a going to
newport i know you're from malibu the
other part was we were looking at
greenwich we were looking at nashville
we were looking at tampa we chose fort
lauderdale and uh again because of his
leadership during times of
turmoil can i interject real quick
it's funny how the governorships played
out the gubernatorial situations
you were considering
california yeah newsom
right
new york
cuomo and then florida desantis so just
interesting how things have played out
this was in 2020 before all the yeah the
the recall and you got really nashville
is also on the list the only thing with
nashville is the lifestyle is not the
lifestyle of here the great thing about
florida is
if california and texas had a baby it'd
be florida yeah you got the lifestyle
plus the taxes and the regulations so
it's a good situation anyways let's get
into uh uh you know your background how
did you end governor desantis get hooked
up to be the press secretary how does
that work out well first i want to take
a step back and talk about you know your
intro it was interesting you know you
bring up these polls about 2024 first
off and i know you know that that
narrative has been out there for quite a
while
but i just want to say governor desantis
has never said anything about 2024 i
mean this is kind of um you know it's a
narrative that's out there whenever he's
been asked directly he always emphasizes
what we know to be true he's running in
2022 he's running this november for
re-election as governor and obviously as
you said i mean he's done a great job
for our state so um while it's nice to
hear some people want him to be
president that's not really on his radar
he's focused on our state focused on
florida and keeping florida free um so
that's actually segues into how i
got the position that i'm in now so
about a year ago
i had just come back from working in
eastern europe i was a political
consultant over there and i was looking
for something new to do during covet and
everything international travel became
very difficult and with the political
situation in the usa changing so rapidly
after the election last year i mean
sorry in 2020 i
started thinking i should get back to my
roots i mean i've always been a
conservative i've always been a
republican and i want to work for a
conservative leader here
desantis was somebody i've been watching
really since the beginning of kovid
because i like the way he was handling
things and i'm sure we're going to go
into that today but essentially that was
it so i wrote a couple of articles um
published them in a conservative
magazine early last year
and um long story short that's what got
me on the radar of the desantis team
and i was invited for an interview and
it turned out that the timing worked out
really well and also i think just the
fact that you know most of the folks in
our office are from florida as governor
desantis is a florida native but
sometimes i think somebody who has lived
in in california and in washington dc
where i was before here um just brings a
bit of a different perspective meaning
like i came from these very liberal
areas and i saw the pitfalls of the
governments there and particularly
during the lockdowns and during the last
couple years when crime has really risen
so i guess i speak from that perspective
as somebody who has that experience and
really appreciates what we have in
florida because it's such a contrast to
like where i came from
that's interesting and by the way this
is uh somebody who's you you said
eastern europe is that ukraine
your specialty is ukraine because we're
going to talk about ukraine today yeah i
know i've worked in ukraine last year in
2020 i was working in georgia the
country um for a while and there's a
pretty similar situation to ukraine
there makes sense makes sense yeah you
know it's a
by the way topics wise we got obviously
governor desantis criticism we'll cover
that with you uh florida we're gonna
talk about ukraine trump sackey
and a couple other things uh uh about
florida but you said something you said
um
the fact that uh the polls we read and
he said you know he's not running for
president he's never said he's running
for president he's running for 2022 but
he's also never said he wouldn't run for
president 2024 so it's kind of like this
the first time tom brady like i'll give
you an example tom brady is uh just lost
to uh who they lose to they lost to uh
the rams the rams they lost here matt
stafford came back and you know won the
game and we thought he was going to win
it but
this is the first time i've heard brady
talk about uh retirement in a very weird
way you know he's not talking retirement
like flat out oh i'm coming back next
season have you noticed he's not said
i'm gonna consult with my family the
first time he's ever been waffling a
little bit he's not definitive so i feel
like the reason why there's all this
chitter chatter about uh ron desantis
because he's not definitive his answer
has not been i'm telling you i'm not
running his answer is right now my focus
is on being a governor of state of
florida that's what florida needs for us
you know what would you say to that
i mean i would say three years is an
eternity in politics like that's a long
ways away it's never really been asked
or expected of any politician to tell
you what they're going to be doing in
three years you know and he's being held
to uh by the media i think they're
they're intimidated by him in many ways
we're going to get to all this criticism
and stuff but i think he's he's almost
being held to being elevated by them and
being held to that kind of standard that
most politicians are not held to so i
would just say yeah three years is a
long time in politics but he has not
said anything about running in 2024. um
i think it's wishful thinking among a
lot of conservatives because obviously
you know looking at what he's done in
florida a lot of people want that for
their states and that's great um but we
are focused on you know
getting him re-elected here yeah yeah
there is one guy i don't know he lives
somewhere in palm beach that i don't
think he has wishful thinking about
desantis running i don't know if you
know what i'm talking about he's uh he's
been around what's his name yeah you you
know a good friend of yours uh
president donald trump who lives at
mar-a-lago which it seems like there's
some uh back and forth going on right
now with the conversations between the
two of them the media you know obviously
needs stories to build up we know that
at the same time you know but but but
also at the same time you know trump
just came up straight out and he said uh
there's some governors out there when
they're asked about boosters they're not
given the real answer even though they
took the booster they took vaccine they
don't want to give the answers i gave
the answer about the booster and it was
kind of you know insinuating maybe
that's governor desantis because the
interview with desantis when he was
asked about the booster it wasn't a
direct answer you don't see any friction
going on between trump and desantis
today no i think you know look at
trump's last appearance on hannity he
gave the exclusive interview to hannity
hannity asked directly about this you
know handy's on very good terms with
both trump and desantis who by the way
are on good terms with each other
president trump confirmed that he said
look you know we're good friends we've
supported each other um he's a great
governor of florida and you know
basically all this narrative of like
friction and tension and all that it's
like great fodder for the media because
it gets clicks and that's really what
they're all about getting the clicks and
driving the traffic and what better way
to do that especially during that
particular week that all this came out
about two weeks ago now it started that
was when biden's agenda was like
crashing and burning it was when it
became clear that their voting
legislation is not going to pass their
build back better is kind of dead on
arrival
mansion and cinema you know the two
democratic senators that defected so it
was like all these big priorities that
biden had oh the supreme court ruled
against the osha vaccine mandate so
these were like failure after failure
for the bite administration on a huge
scale so what better way for the media
that's provided
i think it was a deflection from all of
these i mean i don't know about that and
the reason why i don't know about that i
i have dinner with some very uh you know
people who have who have done well for
themselves and they follow politics very
closely and there is major tension
amongst people who want trump to become
the president again because you know
look let's face it nobody's bragging
about biden right now i mean nobody when
msnbc and cnn are sitting there saying
how this is terrible i mean you know
things are bad when they're saying it's
terrible what's worse than terrible so
no one's talking about biden right now
biden we'll cover a couple things with
biden
but i do see that you know the biggest
concern that comes up is
you look at the stage for debate and you
sit there and you say
okay i don't know if it's a good look if
trump and desentis is up there because
they're both extremely competitive just
an fy for people who don't know who
desantis is here's his background i
don't think a lot of people know this
governor desantis graduated with honors
from yale university by the way this is
not one of those things that some people
say that they graduate honors and then
you realize they're at the bottom of the
class this guy should graduate with
honors at the top of his class we know
another person who claims that captain
of yale's varsity baseball team as a
senior in 2001 he had the team's best
banning average at 336 graduated with
honors from harvard law school
as if yale is not enough wildlife
harvard earned a commission in the u.s
navy as a jag officer supported
operations at the terrorist detention
center of guantanamo bay
after active duty served as federal
prosecutor where he targeted and
convicted child predators he still
serves in the u.s navy reserve and casey
desantis his wife is an emmy
award-winning television host and
descent to spend a year as a history
teacher at darlington school what else
does this man do
i mean is this what else does he do i
mean yeah obviously his background is
incredibly impressive he's an impressive
leader and i think his background shows
that and i think what we see in florida
and his accomplishments it proves that
but you know this whole idea of like a
competition between him and trump how
would they be competing i mean
president trump isn't running for
governor of florida he's he's been
supportive since really since day one
when governor desantis decided to run
and um you know there's no
there's no reason for them to be
competing it's all like i said it's all
kind of like you said people are
speculating about it but that's all it
is it's speculation and it's it's driven
by the media maybe not entirely um maybe
it's some people's personal opinions but
you know i can't really comment on you
know how they say 50 of jokes are true
you ever heard that thing like somebody
talks with you and you're like wait was
that it's funny because it's true yes
one goes it's true i think 50 of
speculations are also i think this is
one of those speculations where i think
it's complete i mean trump just said on
october 3rd 2021 which is what a few
months ago if i faced him i'd beat him
like i would beat everyone else i think
most people would drop out i think he
would also drop out if i'm desantis okay
and his resume graduated from yale with
the honors competitive you captain a
yale varsity team competitive as a
senior in 2001 batting average of 336
competitive graduated with honors at
harvard law school competitive while at
harvard he earns a commission
competitive supported terrorism comp
everything about this i think he was
also a navy seal he was the commander
for navy seal unit is what he was yeah
some of these things we were unaware of
dude he did this but
just yesterday we're sitting over time
we're like do you guys know that and
then everybody's like what are you
talking about he was also i think casted
in the movie mission impossible
speculation on the other half right
but here's the point here's the point
actually
i know competitive people uh
if i faced them i'd beat them like i
would beat everyone else
i think most people would drop out i
think he would drop out i think in that
moment when that was said desantis's
phone probably just went ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
right all these things are coming to him
and the santis with all these
credentials is not going to sit there
and say
what a sweetheart of a guy to say
something like that about me i don't
know if i you know what i'm saying am i
losing you're saying his competitive
juice is my oh my god i think he's
probably sitting there saying if i faced
you i would beat you i think that's what
he'd be thinking from a timing
standpoint let me let you said something
that i actually totally agreed with and
i just kind of want to push it back to
you you said you know it's speculation
and you know three years is a long time
away
and he brought up the tom brady analogy
so i'm gonna throw a sports analogy your
way you tell me if i'm right i'm wrong
and then you respond
you know bill belichick would always say
like listen we're just focused on the
next game i'm not trying to you know i'm
not looking down the road i know we're
playing uh you know the rams two weeks
from now but right now we got the bills
coming up next week so i'm gonna focus
so clearly desantis
you know in november
10 months from now
he's got an election coming up he this
the people of florida will either
re-elect desantis i probably think they
will go for him or they're going to
choose something else so clearly the
next game up is running for governor but
once he wins that and it becomes
apparent like all right this guy's he's
in here i think the fodder will only get
deeper like people started talking about
midterms
the day joe biden was elected so like
two years is down the road i get it but
next thing you know holy [ __ ] it's 2022
or in january and midterms are literally
coming up and he's getting uh you know
he's gonna be coming for election so
i guess do you understand
the fodder especially when it will pick
up after he gets reelected look i
absolutely understand i just feel that
it's overblown because like i'm working
in the office in tallahassee in the
capitol right and i work with governor
desantis and i see what he's doing every
day it's like you know i'm telling you
about november but even sometimes
thinking next week is crazy because
different
like momentous things happen every day
in a huge state like florida with 22
million people and growing um you know
with the covid pandemic and with all the
challenges that we face with the economy
there are so many different crises and
different issues that he has to manage
just on a day to day right like that
even thinking 10 months from now even
thinking about november that isn't even
his top priority of course like he wants
to get reelected but the best way to get
reelected is to do a good job as
governor do a good job in the job that
you're doing yeah and i believe that's
what he is focused on so like when
you're saying his his phone might be
blowing up with like i'm sure people
speculate i mean maybe maybe not i don't
know but um but that just isn't his
focus what he's focused on is is what
he's doing for our state which is an
extremely demanding job and takes up a
lot of time
yeah i i don't disagree like you know
even if you look at 2018 the florida
goober uh you know the the election that
took place for the governor you had ron
desantis got four 4 million 76 000 votes
and you got andrew gillum that got 4
million 43 000 votes wasn't a run-up
like that was a close race that took
place yeah very close so how do you feel
scroll to the see what florida looks
like by the way just from a color
standpoint
okay and florida would have been
drastically different had andrew gillum
got elected i mean he was he was almost
like a gavin newsom california this was
obviously before coveted hit and
everything would have been different
yeah 2018. uh people love florida
because of what desantis did with covet
that was this moment to shine yeah
imagine if andrew gillum had been
elected we would be another california
or new york it would be
180 but you know when you make that
point so here's what it comes down to
okay
there is a
there's a you said 22 million there's 22
million people that
don't want him to run for president they
just don't you know what i'm saying they
want him to say why would you run for
president just relax governor is great
it's one of the biggest economies in the
world why would you want to be president
just stay chill and the people who are
saying that are the people who live in
florida because they love this guy right
minus the few people that would like
more masks on top of masks and would
like you know mandates on top of
mandates but for the most part people
love florida i mean even aoc loves
florida right right yeah aoc eric
swalwell yeah gretchen whitmer governor
of michigan like all these lockdown like
politicians are coming here on vacation
who can blame them yeah who can blame
them i mean i think uc is smart for the
41 decision of coming to florida right
yeah for vacation it's a very good move
on her end but
there is a community here that doesn't
want to now for the other 310 million
people who don't live here a big
majority of those guys are hoping this
guy throws his name in the hat and he
goes out there and competes so whether
that's going to happen or not i have a
feeling you're gonna stick to your
you know your your your script of he's
not gonna run he's gonna run for
governor but let's let's talk about who
he's gonna be facing next how about that
let's talk about who he's gonna be
facing next so we have a story here we
have a story here
who uh uh somebody who didn't say nice
things about uh governor desantis what
what page is that story on by the way
it's talking about nikki friday yeah
nicki free yeah is it page two okay
let's go through uh
uh uh there you go page two okay so uh
desantis democrat challenger compares
them to hitler in a lot of ways this is
yahoo news story florida agriculture
commission democratic uber guber
notorious candidate nikki fried sat down
for an interview friday and compared for
the governor
ron desantis to nazi leader adolf hitler
instead of
listening and trying to govern with the
people he is trying to govern over
people and you know that i'm sorry i'm a
student of history too i saw the rise of
hitler freed 42 told podcast co-host
melissa ross on florida's public radio
on friday regarding florida's governor
desantis when ron asked fred if she was
making a direct comparison between the
census and hitler the agriculture
criminal said in a lot of ways yes i've
studied hitler and how he got to power
you know wanting his own militia frida
explained referencing desantis moved to
reestablish a state guard with 22 other
states also utilized in case of
emergency the reason why this governor
wants it is different than the other
states that have been utilizing it for
emergency purposes the governor is doing
it for the sole purpose of power and
doing so makes fear and blaming certain
parts of society and culture and that's
exactly what hitler did to the jews back
in world war ii so when you hear
comments like this being said and then
your comments back in this article is
nikki fried's claim that governor
desantis is a modern-day hitler's as
offensive as it is absurd with the
hysterical comparison free not only
smears millions of floridians as nazis
but also trivializes hitler's crime
against humanity what do you have to say
about nikki frida as a competitor as an
opponent look i mean she's not serious
anyone who could say something like that
number one she's 44 years old she didn't
see the rise of hitler and it's
offensive because actually there are
some people in florida who are holocaust
survivors who did see the rise of hitler
who did experience these atrocities that
she and i and us we cannot imagine that
and so when she comes out and tries to
compare our governor
to hitler it just it's sick it's
offensive um a number of jewish
organizations came out and explained why
it's offensive um i kind of touched on
it in my quote but like at the end of
the day that is an inappropriate
comparison whether you're a republican
or a democrat whether you can disagree
with somebody without
taking that step particularly because
like the way she explains it about the
state guard
um
as the reporter said to her 22 other
states have this california has it new
york has it states where there are
natural disasters that are very prone to
natural disasters like florida can
really benefit from it because
essentially it just helps with the
national guard right now florida
national guard is deployed to ukraine of
all places they're called up on a
federal mission because national guard
can also like they're actually on
federal missions more than they're on
state missions so in a state like
florida where we get hurricanes and we
get natural disasters we could use that
extra force that extra team of
volunteers who are trained to respond to
emergencies and to compare that to the
gestapo i mean that is sick it's
offensive
to people who actually went through it
and it's offensive to those who are just
trying to help their state today you
know so i i don't think people take
nicki freed very seriously particularly
after this
um but it is just just very sad that
this is the level of political debate
that we're having adam what do you think
about that i mean as a floridian
yourself you hear a comma like that
taking place from somebody who's going
up against uh uh uh desantis and by the
way this is somebody that's pro
uh a concealed weapon like she's okay
with you so she's got some interesting
beliefs first woman to be elected as a
florida commission of agriculture
pro-concealed carry and pro-medical
marijuana referred to governor desantis
as hitler obviously only democrat to win
a statewide office in 2018 elections one
of 17 speakers to jointly deliver
keynote as democratic national
commission the dnc graduated from
university florida masters in political
campaigning supports voting rights for
felons excluding murderers and sex
offenders what do you think about when
you hear somebody like this make a
comment like this i don't know much
about nicki frida i think she did
graduate from university of florida and
she's a few years older than us but
here's what i'll say about the hitler
thing uh and full disclosure i had i'm
jewish i had my grandparents family
cousins they died in in nazi germany you
said it trivializes exactly what he did
now
it does one of two things for me at
least
any person with common sense i'm not
even talking republican democrat just
common sense is going to look at this
and be like what the are you talking
about here like do you understand how
stupid this makes you look and just like
because ron desantis might have more
conservative values now he's [ __ ]
hitler what are we talking about here um
but then
so anyone with common sense is just like
whatever but then there's going to be
people
who listen to this
and maybe don't follow the news or
follow media and they're like no
he's he's a hitler yeah and and they go
down this rabbit hole of just absurdity
and then that's begins to pick up fodder
so we've seen it happen like
people used to say like
you know what george bush he's kind of
like hitler oh that's mitt romney you
guys you know he's like a hitler
trump you know and just like
okay
enough's enough with the hitler thing so
for you as the press secretary your job
is to
defend ron desantis are there certain
things that you're just like listen i
just like just
this is [ __ ] this is i don't want to
say that word but like this is so absurd
that i don't even want to answer this or
is it like no it's my job i actually
have to
rebuttal such a ridiculous comment how
does that work i mean that's how i see
it it is my job but it really depends on
the source right so if it's just a
random person tweeting some nonsense
about the governor i'm not going to
elevate it or give it attention right
but if it's a statewide official which
nicki freed is or if it's a major media
outlet like the associated press
you know no matter how absurd or
ridiculous the line of attack is i do
have to address it i mean that is my job
unfortunately you know i like i said i
wish we were talking more about
substantive issues versus this kind of
crazy rhetoric but you know she brought
it to that point so
we had to respond and i think like i
said there are a lot of folks like you
in florida who have relatives who have
ancestors who actually experienced these
crimes in nazi germany who were victims
of hitler and so to be talking like this
for her it's just it's it's really
inappropriate and who is she in the
context of the state of florida
what does she do exactly so she's the
agriculture commissioner but that's a
really big position in florida it not
only includes agriculture which we're a
big agricultural state but also it
includes issuing permits for concealed
carried weapons it includes consumer
services so like reports of fraud her
office handles a lot of stuff related to
that so it's a pretty big position
unfortunately though you know
since she's been elected she's been
campaigning for governor basically she's
been using her office instead of
actually doing her job to help
agriculture thrive and to issue these
permits she is
just tweeting about governor desantis
all day well she's attacking you know
the guy at the job who in your mind is
the most likely candidate or candidates
to face off with ron desantis in
uh november well there's charlie crist
is he running again because right now
you're looking at some of the polls the
reason why we brought her up she just
passed up charlie cruz oh did she yeah i
mean fundraising a lot of post has her
ahead of him some have him over her
but uh
what is really the biggest difference
between him or charlie crist
i mean charlie crist was governor
already
and he was a republican when he was
governor and
then he turned and he became a senator
and yeah he's a
he's as swampy as it gets in florida
right he's been back forth left right up
down yeah governor senator you know he's
been independent republican democrat and
so i think that's the big difference i
mean that he is
so nikki is younger she's always been a
democrat you know maybe some democrats
would trust her more because of that um
that she hasn't been a party switcher
charlie crist has been all over the
place i think what's really offensive
about charlie chris i mean there's many
things but one is in 2019
he visited communist cuba took pictures
with the communist regime there like
with officials there and that was online
as basically pro-government propaganda
websites in cuba are showing this as
though charlie crist supports them and i
know he was well he said that he was
just trying to
build the diplomatic relationship
um there are a lot of cuban americans in
florida so he thought you know this
would be a good idea but i think it's
it's very offensive because the cuban
americans here they escape from that for
a reason
and they don't want to like see an
american politician who wants to
represent them
legitimizing this regime who's the
brutal regime but who sits there and
tells you it's a good idea to do that
and by the way you're representing
florida like i'm curious you know who
the marketing person is saying hey
charlie we should go to florida and say
you know we should go to cuba and take a
picture what are you thinking i mean
look i'm glad i'm not his press
secretary because i could not make
excuses for that i could not spin that i
mean that's just sickening and governor
desantis has always been you know a huge
supporter of freedom in cuba and that's
why i think you know he does have a lot
of support among that community and they
can see he's not a dictator so these
comparisons like like chris actually
after nicki free compared to hitler
chris hit back he's actually more like
castro come on you're going to call
governor de santis castro but you're
hanging out but let's define that though
let's define that okay so what what is
castro what is hitler the word that
comes to my mind is force right that's
what force is isn't that the real uh
mo of those extreme
the most extreme type of force
what so what is the definition of
dictatorship can you pull up tyler the
definition of dictatorship hopefully it
hasn't changed to a sweetheart of a
person who loves their people and
hopefully they've kept the definition uh
all right let's see what is the
definition of dictator 40 years of
dictator i want to know the definition
of dictatorship type in dictatorship is
a former grand character as a single
leader or group of leaders that whole
government power promise to the people
in little or no toleration for political
pluralism or independent media okay so
can you go back to the images real quick
that you just had
i thought i saw something that
is that george bush and obama as
this is exactly what i'm talking about
here is when you use
such rhetoric yeah for people that are
actually decent you lose your your
argument yeah right you're right so the
moment you drop that word hitler you
lose credibility with me the moment you
dropped that word on both sides by the
way yeah and it's being totally fine but
let me go back to this whole thing with
calling him the dictator when you think
about the word dictator what word you
think about i i'll give you a couple
words i got you said one i said force
you said what you said uh um i think of
death
but what do you think about when you
think about the word dictator what do
you think about words specific words
control control okay i agree
totalitarian totalitarian so let's say
force and control okay all right so tell
me what is force and control is force
forcing everyone to take the vaccine is
that force mandates so isn't that a form
of mandate so if nikki really needs to
redefine what she means by that to
understand how she went through the
military side seeing like 22 different
states i understand what part she's
going to yeah but florida as much crap
as people talk about florida the nba
playoffs was in florida
the
a bunch of ufc a bunch of comedians
comedians are moving forward
yeah i mean if you look at how many
different as if florida
sucks as bad as it does why do you keep
doing events in florida why don't you go
to different places why is it that the
number you know what's the number one
city in america for conventions do you
know some numbers orlando orlando's
number one in america most people think
it's vegas believe it or not orlando's
number one did you know that or no i got
to go to orlando
i'm in orlando two weeks for convention
orlando's number one for convention so
when you drop names like words like that
you got to be very careful because you
lose credibility with the people in the
middle that are somewhat reasonable well
what you're basically saying is like
okay on the surface it's ridiculous
like the hitler comments yeah the
dictator comments but then when you
actually unpack it and really start
throwing definitions out there and being
like okay what is actually freedom it's
like well like gerardo he says a free
state of florida love it free state of
florida and then it just compels your
argument even further right i mean what
kind of dictator tells parents you get
to choose if your kid wears a mask or
gets a vaccine or not whereas in other
states the governor mandates one way
like that has to be done with no
exceptions or like they let local
governments mandate it and governor
desantis said no everyone gets to assess
their own risk make the right decisions
for their kids everyone is different you
know and that's the opposite of what a
real dictator would do choice yeah
exactly the opposite of choice but by
the way a very serious question i i'd
love to hear serious answer from you
this does jan sackey ever call you does
she ever call you
does you guys ever talk at all or no we
don't i mean like i
i know that she's kind of
not mentioned me by name but she's
alluded to some of the stuff i've said
like during her press conferences she
will kind of throw shade at us um she
likes hating on florida but i think i
know why though i know why can i make my
speculation this is pure speculation so
remember 50 50 world we're following
with the speculation
uh
i don't know how much you work every day
i think you probably work 30 minutes a
day you and let me explain to you why i
think sack is jealous of you
because jen seki is probably working 24
hours a day having to fix everything
biden does 24 7. i think for you your
job is easy desantis gets up on camera
you're like
okay that makes sense all right this
makes sense you know i feel like your
job is a pretty easy job today that's on
point i mean look and i mean in the most
respectful way i don't mean it in a way
i get what you mean because he says what
he means he he fact checks everything he
says before he says it so i don't have
to play clean up like jen does with with
president biden
but also you know my job is harder in
one way which is the media the media i
mean most mainstream media is totally
against desantis and they're totally
pro-biden
it's there are exceptions of course but
i think so our jobs are easy and
difficult but for different reasons
are you saying the local media or the
national media local media is much more
fair in florida because i think they
they know what's going on here they live
here right and they have access to the
governor they can ask him questions and
everything so so they've treated us more
fairly the national media has its own
totally own agenda and and they
try to they go out of their way to cover
for biden they have to they have to do
that because when
but by the way to be fair to her how
much she's working and saki i i don't
think sake is working any harder than
sean spicer had to work or sarah
huckabee sanders or caitlyn mcinanny
very tough jobs defending trump and
biden
there's no question about it okay kelly
caramucci lasted like eight days and
then seven events okay and then like
hanukkah came up and he had to go yeah
but by the way that's why i have so much
respect for kellyanne conway i think
kelly you know who kellyanne conway is i
mean kellyanne conway is trump's dennis
rodman okay
she has to do the dirty job she's got
the hair
elbow
i was like michael you just go i got you
man don't worry about it i got you you
know he goes out there and does what he
does are you a fan of kellyanne conway
who are you a fan of because you said
you're a conservative you're you're
female you know you're blonde like kelly
you're not throwing that out there but
is there somebody
in the press secretary world or
spokesman world for politicians you're
like
kellyanne conway that's my girl or
you know saki or anyone who who is your
role models in this in this uh in your
job honestly
i i like kellyanne i think she did a
great job i think kaylee mcannie did a
fantastic job i love that she was
you know polite but firm with the press
and she always had the facts on her side
like you you can't just like hit back at
the press by calling them names you have
to have the facts and so that's what i
liked about her um sarah sanders was
also really good so you know there's a
lot of folks that i think are good
spokes people saki is a good
spokesperson i don't agree with her on
anything but she can spin and her job is
hard because like remember last week
biden said that a minor incursion of
russia into ukraine is is okay basically
and she had to work to walk that back i
mean that's
a tough job i totally agree i actually
think i'm i think as ability-wise i
think janet's actually good at her job
well like what tough job it's a tough
job how much leeway do you have meaning
does he say look this is the script
whether it's trump biden desantis
you're his mouthpiece it's not like he's
coming on and doing the pbd podcast yet
but
you know you have to represent them how
much you say listen i trust you just do
your thing you know we've talked about
this or it's like stick to the script
this is what it is if you screw up we're
gonna come like
how does it work your job well i think
it's different for every politician but
with governor desantis i'm really lucky
because
i do get a good amount of leeway what
that means is though
i have a high expectation of me too that
i can't just go injecting my own
opinions if it's different or like going
off script and talking about stuff that
has nothing to do with what he's doing
as governor right but i think it's
helpful that i actually agree with him
on everything i don't know that i could
be defending a boss that i didn't agree
with i think it would be a very
difficult job in that case but because i
do agree with him i think it's easy also
he's very um active like he gives press
conferences almost every day he gives or
like a speech or something like he
speaks almost every day and so there's
just a lot of content to go off of i
know what he would say about something
like all of these big issues he's asked
about it a lot he does interviews
frequently and so like there's i i just
pretty much know what his responses
would be so if i can base my responses
on what he has said but i can add my own
flair to it you know like and i actually
i feel like i have more of an ability to
hit back when there's like fake news or
when there is a personal attack from
nikki freed if the governor hits back it
elevates that person but me as a
spokesperson as a staff member like i
can do it and not risk that same like
elevation yeah you're the flat carrier
you're playing the role of a flag here
dennis rodman she she is a friendly
dennis rod but i'm telling you that is
by far if you ever build a team you have
to have somebody that is a little bit
you know it's willing to get i don't
think how much
fire and under pressure kellyanne conway
had to deal with and she wasn't why
would you say that i mean trump has to
be one of the biggest sweethearts we've
had as a president in the last however
long anyway so uh you know you said
something and i want to put this back on
you and maybe uh
you know see where you'll go with this
do you think um
so so this is not for 2024 long term
is is governor desantis aspirations to
one day be a president
honestly i don't know because i've with
all the time that i work with him i've
never heard him say that either way i
think he would make a great president if
he wanted to do that but he's never said
anything that would make me think that
he's focused on anything but being the
governor of florida like i said he wants
to do his job the best he can every day
and it's such a it is a big job um
particularly with all the challenges
we're facing from the federal government
right now um and so i think he is taking
it like i don't want to say one day at a
time because he does think longer term
for certain things but but um i don't
think he sits around dreaming about
a higher position i don't think he's in
the hillary clinton camp i think she's
been dreaming it since she was 14. he's
a different he's a guy
i don't think him and hillary have
similar dna i don't see that i think
he's safe to be around uh but uh you
know in regards to the question i'm
asking long term here's where i'm going
with it i think if you're listening to
this how many guys listen to this think
long term you know when he talks to
casey by the way how's his wife doing is
health how's everything there well
thanks for asking i mean we got great
news last week actually um they
announced that she did her last chemo
treatment so we're really happy about
that obviously there's a few more things
um that she'll be doing but the governor
said a couple weeks ago he expects that
this is the year 2022 is the year that
they can finally say like she's
cancer-free and that's amazing i mean
you know she's done such a great job as
first lady and she's still you know even
with her treatment and everything she's
still out there and she's she's always
so supportive yeah i think sometimes we
forget that this is you know still a
human being you know at the end of the
day you're still going home to a family
that was going to be my question is that
we're we're talking politics we're
talking running we're talking you know
races at the end of the day he has to go
home and he's got two kids three kids
three kids and his wife is dealing with
cancer yeah on top of everything just as
a human how have you seen his mental
health through all the challenges he's
had to deal with look obviously looking
at his background you can see he's a
strong person
um
he
is really dedicated to his family i
think his family gives him strength
right so like after the tragedy and surf
side in june um where the building comes
family lives 10 blocks away from there
oh wow i'm sorry to hear i mean it was a
terrible time it was crazy it was right
a month after i started working and it
was like the worst thing i've ever seen
in my life we're down there every day
for about two weeks and then we come
back so like imagine flying from
tallahassee to miami every morning like
getting on the plane at six a.m coming
down there's always an 8 am like stand
up meeting with all the emergency
managers and the county and everything
and so there's all of this and most
governors i think in that situation
would have just stayed down in miami uh
at four seasons in surf side and just
like been there and been working there
but he would and he would go every day
he would do everything that they needed
like whatever he could help with he
would make it clear like he's there to
help but he would go home every night be
home by like seven to be with his kids
have dinner with his wife um you know
and still so balancing that family with
these enormous responsibilities of being
the governor i think that's given him a
lot of strength and you know i think um
that's one of the main reasons why he's
so successful i think as a politician
yeah let me give pat a little shout out
so pat is a family man pat just had his
fourth kid congrats um thank you he's
very open about his relationship with
his wife with his kids and he talks
about his kids and
i think it makes pat the businessman the
entrepreneur
the capitalist way more human and people
like pat for his beliefs and his belief
system and his values and his principles
but they're also like
man what a g i want to like i want to be
a dad like that i want it like what a
what a guy you know like there's there's
like the policy side and the persona
side do you think ron desantis has done
a good job of the
the persona side of things meaning
clearly he's done a pretty good job on
the policy side of things do you think
he can improve being
more like everything i didn't know about
any of that like the the back and forth
do you think he could do a better job of
just
being more human and being just like a
dude like i didn't know he was a navy
seal and he's on the baseball team do
you think that's something that is
lacking from his you know luster around
desantis the the human side of him
that's interesting because i don't think
it's a persona i think this is really
who he is if it was a persona then you
would see it being marketed everywhere
you know but if you don't know about it
you kind of have to market it so that's
the thing i think your question is more
directed at me and our communications
team versus like about him like he is
who he is um but if you're asking if if
his team could do a better job promoting
the human side and like introducing
people to his human side
maybe so i mean i'm always willing to
improve i'm the last person to say that
i'm doing my job perfectly so that is
something that i'd like to do more of
and i think the first lady has helped
with that a lot i mean whenever she does
any kind of media appearances like she
is the best person to
share that side of him like this
different side of him that that most
people don't see
let me let me ask you do you guys have a
director of digital media we do yeah and
is that person's background like heavy
heavy experience social like you know
who have had videos going viral and
short clips and tick tock and facebook
and all of that yeah more so twitter and
facebook we we're not so much on tick
tock um but that might change but yeah i
could see ronda sand is busting a nasty
wig
no i will tell you though you know i
will tell you though the reason why i
asked that question is because
um two people were very good in that
area two people
one was uh
one was obama and the other one was
trump both of them were fantastic they
knew how to get a short cop out
immediately the the one statement where
hillary is like yeah because if you were
in this and until trump says yeah
because you'd be in jail that thing got
a few hundred million views the next day
right and they cut the short clip out
asap so you know i just went on tick
tock and i typed in the santas hashtag
how many total views do you think tick
tock has with the hashtag desantis how
many total views what do you think the
numbers just desantis hashtag ten
thousand no no no i mean you look let me
give you more no i mean a million views
uh stop let me just give you some
comparable you got a million views what
are you talking about if i type in okay
if i type in my hashtag it's 12 million
views okay what do you think the word
desantis in tiktok hashtag how many of
you i think you're getting at it
whatever the number is it should be a
lot more okay it's 205 million views i
don't think that's enough okay if i go
type in biden okay
it should be
you know
15 billion views is what he's got okay
if i go to trump
and and then i want to go to governor
just so you know you'll see where i'm
going with this trump is 21 billion
views right
i go and watch how many
moments desantis had where was a mic
drop moment okay there's a lot there are
no it's not a it's a lot i mean
you could have your directive digital
media be working
for a month and come out with 200 short
clips and they're 15 to 30 seconds
and just put it there and just put it
there right on tick tock on twitter on
facebook on instagram and then everybody
starts picking it up everybody starts
sharing it i think if the reason why i
was asking a question earlier if he has
aspirations of running president long
term and your answer was i don't have
the answer to that question i would love
to see him i don't think he's a guy that
sits around talking about presidency and
i said hillary clinton is one more
aspiration from day one i don't think
he's that guy but i will tell you i
think there comes a time where
the conversation behind closed doors is
the following this is kind of where i'm
going with you
um
certain things
have to do with momentum
you can never uh you think momentum is
always going to be around you know
momentum is
most of the time like you know how a guy
dates a girl they're like oh my gosh
that's a keeper right there he screws it
up and then 10 years later it's like man
i had her but i lost her and now she's
married happily with three kids with
another guy man that could be my wife or
vice versa [ __ ] i was dating him dude i
was a keeper i totally ruined that
relationship look at him now he could
have been my husband right we all go
through this as people that we live our
lives the reason why i asked the
question why a lot of people are also
being uh speculating about him running
next is because you can't bank on having
many more
opportunities like this with momentum as
he has today and and i'm going to make
my case and then you can you know
give us the answer that a proper press
secretary will give
without the answer that you're supposed
to give and we'll receive it we'll
receive to the best of our abilities but
let's look through this he was trashed a
year and a half ago when covet came he
was destroyed okay
we're sitting there in dallas watching
the news florida's the highest and then
we would go to breakers and all of a
sudden though i'll never forget we went
to breakers went to a restaurant the
waiter came in
folks you have to put your masks on why
because here's what just happened and
it's prime cover this year and a half
ago we're talking about like march or
april whatever it was right put your
masks on put you because palm beach
county did this
cuomo was a hero
we thought cuomo was going to be the
next david letterman have his own show
with chris cuomo you thought he was
going to take over
you thought newsome was going to be the
president of the world of the free world
not even u.s he was going to be the
president of you know new world order on
how they were selling him
you thought the you know fauci was a
doctor from another world a level of
dimensions of intelligence that we just
don't have do you like you looked at
everybody and he said trump he's got to
be the worst president of all time right
a lot of the worst president of all time
all these you know things that are
coming out
and then he loses the election
okay biden takes over right
and then next thing you know everybody's
like yeah you know this is
and then
trump got vaccine done in nine months
and pfizer announces the vaccine or
modern or johnson and johnson three days
after the election which you remember
that was literally three days after you
couldn't have done that three days
before the election you had to do it
three days after fine no problem
strategic totally good i'm sure there
was some phone calls on the back end
with pfizer having given a lot of money
to cnn msnbc all these other guys hey
wait three days before you make that
announcement if you don't have they had
it sooner again pure speculation
uh then they saw the handling of it then
they saw cases then they saw the economy
then they saw what happened and then
america kind of sat there and said dude
maybe a part of what trump did was right
maybe this fouchy guy that we trusted
under trump and biden the problem is the
same maybe we need to get rid of him and
maybe this governor out of florida dude
the guy freaking crushed it
you know he kept people free everybody
went through there
for a massive crisis like this to happen
you know crisis in chinese got two
meaning right opportunity and danger for
a massive crisis like this to happen and
for desantis to not capitalize today you
think 2028 is going to be the same
people forget people very quickly
people forget how mayor giuliani was
pretty much the president when 9 11
happened everybody looked at giuliani so
for me
i i just think there's a part of it and
i know what answer you're going to give
and i respect the answer you're going to
give i'm just saying i think the people
that are sitting there watching this or
the people that are saying he ought to
run
i don't want him to run
i'm in florida i'm happy with the
governor he is but i think a lot of
people that want to see him run i think
they have a right argument and if he
does have any aspirations privately you
can't disclose it to other people
because we know what happens you can
probably only trust two or three people
to say that to one is your wife
and maybe a couple other conciliaries
people you trust at your
council
but if there's ever been a time that he
has to make a run for it it's now
if he doesn't i don't know if the
opportunity will be this hot five years
from now 13 years from now
20 years from now um i just don't see
that happening that's why a lot of
people who say he's got to run i think
they have a good argument for it what do
you have to say about that look i hear
you i mean i hear what you're saying i
think it's a fair argument i think you
made some good points there um but i'm
going to say what i'm going to say i
mean i'm not going to keep repeating
myself you know um i i do think though
there's one point that i wanted to go
back to about andrew gillum the
challenger in 2018 almost close race
yeah very close race 30 000 40 000 votes
in a state of 22 million people it's
crazy if that had gone the other way
which it very well might have sure
not only would florida be totally
different but the entire country would
be because florida
is the first big state that really
reopened and really
where we have a leader who actually made
the tough decisions and the tough calls
first even before many conservative
governors did um and they followed in
his footsteps you know like taking away
the mask mandates in the local counties
taking away the school mass man making
it optional for parents to decide like
these are things that he was attacked he
was even attacked on opening schools in
august of 2020. he was sued by the
teachers union there were so many
protests like it was a lot of drama but
he stood up and he did it and if that if
there was no governor who would actually
lead on stuff like that we would be like
china right now i feel like not only
florida but the entire country would be
because as you were saying i mean cuomo
was the hero newsom was the hero
governor desantis was the
um
the
basically demonized by the press and and
during that time now he's turned out to
be right on so many things and florida
has been the control meaning like
florida is the proof that you don't need
these mandates you don't need these
lockdowns you don't need these
restrictions our death rate is lower
than many of these lockdown and
restricted states despite the fact that
we have a much older population than a
lot of these states so higher risk
people so essentially you're saying
florida was a case study for what works
and i agree with that but what you just
said just validated my point on why he
ought to run that just validates my or
why he should stay governor it could
validate either point well yes but it
valid but but the but the part then
becomes what is a bigger problem is the
i i have a feeling he's a crusade type
of guy i have a feeling he loves america
more than he loves florida is that a
pretty fair question to ask i don't
think you can say he loves florida
florida is america right now but i think
but but i think to me america is the
constitution america is the federalist
paper america is not florida is i think
i think to him if he's a crusade guy
which i believe he is i think he to him
you know
florida is a job that was up there for
him to take and he took it and he's done
a great job with it but i think for him
america
matters
more than florida does not saying that
florida is not important please don't
take it that way but it's kind of like
your kid and the wife you love your kids
but man you know this thing was founded
based on your wife
your family there's a certain lineage
[ __ ] out i think america is kind of
maybe again
selfish i don't want them to run you
have to understand i'm here i don't want
the
uh you know
the the former governor that almost won
by 30 000 only lost by thirty thousand
votes but i'm saying case wise
if he loves america more
america kind of is looking for someone
to wanna run my only concern is the
face-off between him and trump how ugly
that's going to be that's why he asked
does he love america more than florida
again there's so much there's so many
real concrete things we could talk about
so i don't know that we need to keep
speculating about that
but um what i can say is florida is what
america should be florida is the ideals
that america was founded on which is
individual rights which is liberty which
is freedom which is protection from
government tyranny right we're founded
on a revolution against government
tyranny we've been a magnet for refugees
and i know you came here as a refugee so
from all over tyrannies all over the
world that came here for a better life
so it's like you know to say that to
choose between america and florida i
don't think it's really the right
framework i think you look at florida
under desantis as what america is was
and should be but unfortunately some
other states with these more
dictatorship type of policies they are
moving away from by the way
after this interview's over
everything you just said go back and
watch that because let me tell you
something
florida
never had that reputation of being the
bastion of freedom and being this place
where you know the whole country is
looking at as a case example florida has
been mocked for decades of being like
this like sunny place for shady people
florida man florida man i'm sure we've
got some stories with that and this is
what ron de santa should run on whether
it's in 22 or 24 or 28 is that i have
changed florida's reputation i've lived
in florida my whole life i've never
heard anybody address florida the way
that you just addressed florida as being
this
uh the great hope of america it's it's
like i'm almost like proud but also
laughing on the inside i'm like did you
really just frickin say that about
florida so that is what ron de santa
should run on and i'm not the only one
you know you were just talking about all
these people moving here from new york
from california from new jersey
from all these different states and why
are they moving here it's because that's
the feeling that they have that's the
impression they have in florida i have a
friend i dinner with last night she's
from brooklyn she has little kids she
was tired of them eating on the concrete
outside of school because of the mask
mandate and because they had to eat
lunch out there because of covet now
they're living a normal life in boca and
they get to have a childhood and you
can't put a price on that you know like
that is something that just it is the
number one thing for most parents
wanting their kids to have a good life
and that this is what governor desantis
has given people from all over the
country this kind of hope you can run on
that that's for sure and i know pat has
has beaten the dead horse with the trump
stuff but i'll give you a different
perspective and then i'm sure we can we
can move on he doesn't want desantis to
run because of
you know every the great job he's done
in florida uh i actually do
and i've been very open about this i do
not want to see trump again at all and
i'm a little disenfranchised with biden
full disclosure i voted for biden
did not want trump again but whether
it's age whether it's persona i think
america is ready for something new
something fresh something that can
hopefully unify the country that we can
get around yeah maybe you didn't like
trump but this guy is crushing florida
and he's well he's ready to be a unifier
potentially so that's what i think is
what is drawing this desantis into the
national you know picture so much is
that there's so much yearning out there
just please not trump again please let's
get by now there's so much of that and
that's why desantis like for instance in
the cpac poll trump at 55 the only
person even close was desantis so the
media and just normal people are
latching on to someone like desantis as
like almost like
the great white hope so i know
obviously deflect it's all good he's not
running he has to focus on florida i'm
just like that's the reason why people
are like come on bro
that's
my perspective i mean i respect that i
respect your perspective but i just
this this whole conflict doesn't exist
right now it exists in in some people's
minds right
but
it's not materially real so i'm hoping
we could talk about some stuff that is
yeah let's talk about crt let's talk
about crt i i think we we kind of got an
idea what the answer is going to be it's
like a broken record so we understand
but
we get it and we made our point and you
made your point as well so
uh uh florida school district cancels
real history as an anti-crt censorship
spread the day after the florida state
senate education committee passed the
bill banning public schools and private
businesses from making people real or
feel discomfort when learning about u.s
racial history a school district in
central florida canceled a teacher
training seminar about the civil rights
movement that had been months in the
planning j michael butler history
professor at flagler college in saint
augustine planned three presentations
covering historic milestones like the
brown versus board of education decision
the march on washington the integration
of the university of mississippi and
montgomery bus boycott to butler this
was not just the culmination of
florida's year-long demonetization
of so-called critical race theory but
also the realization of something he
warned his students about years ago when
our former president used the term fake
news i told my class to be aware of
what's coming next and that's fake
history if there's a topic that can be
censored today that means there's a
precedent for the censoring of any topic
in any state moving forward and that
should scare all teachers what are your
thoughts on that
well there's a lot to unpack there i
should start out by saying this idea
that critical race theory and history is
the same thing is a lie that is
completely dishonest critical race
theory is a theory
history is about facts so we know for
example that there was slavery in
america that is a fact
a sad fact is that there is also
segregation after slavery there was jim
crow laws there was all kinds of racist
policies that have fortunately changed
after the civil rights movement and now
i do believe
people do have equal opportunities here
now
say critical race theory it's a theory
based on marxism but basically instead
of a class conflict and class as your
identity group
it splits people into identity groups
based on race so it says no matter what
your background is and no matter who
your parents are
if you're born white
you're an oppressor
if you're born black you're oppressed
and that's no that's not that's the
opposite of what america is based on
that's the opposite of our values the
reason why so many people come here of
all races from all over the world is
because it is
the only place in the world really that
you can come and you can reinvent
yourself and you can pursue what you
want to do in many other countries
including where i used to live in
eastern europe you're kind of born into
a certain family and it limits your
opportunities in some way it limits what
you could do and so
i think critical race theory it's
dangerous in a diverse society as we
have florida is a very diverse state so
to be segregating kids and telling kids
that are like five to eight years old
like saying that basically making them
feel that they're responsible for
historical injustices
is ridiculous it's dangerous it causes
divisions when we already have a pretty
divided society we don't want to make
that worse
and i should add that florida law
requires all public schools to teach
facts about history including
african-american history that's in the
law it says like there's a statute on
teaching african-american history and
what has to be in it and so there are
standards first amendment rights apply
to people they don't apply to the
government schools are part of the
government i mean public schools so they
have to teach a certain curriculum and
that curriculum is prescribed by state
law it includes facts it includes facts
about the holocaust it includes facts
about slavery you cannot deviate from
those facts and give your own personal
opinions about it based on your ideology
you have to teach what the standards are
right and so this is number one i i
don't like this framing of the whole
article um
and number two you know
telling parents that their concerns are
not real that crt isn't really being
taught in schools or that
they're just racists maybe and they
don't want kids to learn real history
this isn't effective we saw what
happened in the virginia governor's race
virginia went for biden by 10 points
a republican won by two points 12 point
swing in one year because of this issue
in part education was the big issue
because parents of all races by the way
were seeing what their kids are being
taught and they were horrified by it
they were shocked by it i mean like and
it makes sense because
you know it's it's the absolute opposite
of factual history at the end of the day
like to teach that america is founded on
racism and this kind of stuff
but by the way tyler what is the
definition of racism just racist type in
racist definition i'm curious you know
what comes up and pull it up on
duckduckgo and pull it up on google uh
make it right there to the left yeah if
you make it a little bigger okay
adjective noun a person who is
prejudiced
against or antagonistic toward people on
the basis of their membership in a
particular racial or ethnic group
typically one that is a minority or
marginalized he has been targeted by
vicious racist
online prejudice against or antagonistic
towards a person or people okay got it
uh can you go to duckduckgo and let you
see what it says on there so the duck
duck goes as a uh is a noun a person who
a person who believes a particular
particular race is superior to others so
your race is superior than somebody
else's i mean it's a completely
different definition than what's on
google you think in your race is
superior to others
okay so hitler thought his race was
superior to others that's historical
racism is a belief that groups of human
possesses different behavioral traits
corresponding to inherited attributes
and can be divided based on the
superiority of one race over another
is that is that going on in america
today there are racist people okay in
america as there have been throughout
history there have been racists in
history you named one hitler but there
have been racists in america as well
that does not mean that society is
racist that doesn't mean that our entire
system is racist and needs to be
destroyed and rebuilt as something else
you know it means that we need to work
towards
marginalizing
those racist voices like you know a
generation ago we had governors in the
south um who were pro-segregation
who were supported the idea that black
people could not eat at the same lunch
counter as white people
fortunately we've gotten rid of that
that had to happen they had to be
marginalized from politics leaders like
this who would support these policies
but
at the end of the day
today you don't see that anymore um what
you do see though is a different kind of
racism which is basically
teaching kids that they're responsible
for the crimes of their ancestors
um that's just wrong
and then
telling kids that they are oppressed or
that they're victims of a system based
on their race even if they are not even
if they have the same opportunities as
anyone else and what critical race
theory is
it is
basically saying
that um
your race defines who you are and we
don't believe that i mean we believe
governor desantis believes that your
experiences your interests your
individuality defines who you are
it's it's not like collectivism it's
toxic so i was in uh uh but did you have
any racist friends growing up or anybody
not the two drop any names so did you
experience this one guy rick he was busy
[ __ ]
i'm serious with you like yeah i mean
there's some yes okay so i i did as well
i was in south carolina in the army and
i went out and uh
my dad came to see me for graduation so
we went into south carolina if you know
south carolina what is capital for
capital of south carolina is
you know you guys are literally a
confederate flag exactly that's what i'm
saying to you so i went out i'm like oh
wow there's some of this taking place
where are you from and i was no hair at
that time i mean bald it's not the
friendliest look i got right so i'm
walking around and people look at me i'm
having confidence i'm like why these
guys really do look at me as a threat
coming from iran but i will tell you
what concerns me about what you just
said
so this weekend uh we went shopping in
miami with the kids i took tikka and
dylan because senator went to a birthday
party that the boys weren't invited
because you have to be three to five to
go to the birthday party and they didn't
qualify because they're eight and nine
so mommy kicked us out she went to the
birthday party with babies and i said
let's go shopping
we go to miami it's me tico dillon and
sam and
tico says daddy can we get some gelato i
said uh well let's see how you guys
going to behave and we'll get some
gelato and believe me i want some gelato
myself so i want to go get some gelato
because that is going to happen please
behave
and then uh tico makes a comment he says
daddy you're such a fun destroyer i said
i'm a what you're a fun destroyer i said
no problem i said perfect i said tico
let me teach you a lesson about life
if you tell me i'm a fun destroyer i'm
going to act like a fun destroyer
because you made me believe as a father
i'm a fun destroyer so we go can we get
gelato no i'm a fun destroyer i'm
committed to being a fun destroyer so we
walk we go to nike i can't believe
you're doing this daddy i i didn't mean
it i said no i believe it now because
you said it with so much conviction i
believe i'm a fun destroyer so i'm going
to be committed for being a fun
destroyer for an hour and a half i play
the role of a fun destroyer makes sense
played it well so i said to him i said
so can you explain to me
uh uh do you understand why it's so
power i said have you dylan have you
ever heard me call you a loser no why
i i don't know because i'm not yeah
because if i call you you believe it
because you're not a loser i'll call you
a loser i said if you call me a fun
destroyer as a father i think i'm a fun
destroyer as a father maybe i become a
fun destroyer as a father then tico said
oh that's starting to make sense so
let's play a game together so what's
that
tico what can you say good about dylan
what are some good things about dylan i
think dylan is smart i think dylan is
this i think dylan as i said dylan how
about you about tico he says well daddy
tico sometimes doesn't share the games
with me i said no no only good so
dylan's trying to make an effort to say
something good about his brother they
had a big fight this morning in the
house which was epic anyways by the time
i was on a satiko did my point make
sense he says yeah daddy you're
definitely not a fun distressed tell me
why i'm not a fun destroyer he says you
always wrestle with us you always do
this i say okay so the meaning of fun
destroy you have to be very careful
using that word because words have
weight right they carry a lot of weight
if you tell a
eight-year-old kid
you're racist because of your lineage
dude i can only imagine if somebody
tells that to me 50 40 100 times i'm
gonna start believing it now you're
giving birth to a generation that grow
up
hating their own lineage i look you read
the bible and see what happened to
assyrians one of the greatest famines
about assyrians 180 something thousand
right god wasn't a big fan of assyrians
if you read some of the history of what
they did because they thought they could
be bigger than god and they built this
empire to go up there and if you don't
know the history of assyrians they're
very interesting people right assyrians
but guess what what are we going to sit
there and say oh because of that
let me tell you
you are you know
you're responsible for that no that's
what they did but people change and we
can get better and you just have to be
careful to not put me in a box that just
because i'm that i'm doing that as well
so very surprising virginia told us
that to parents
voting for your side of the aisle is
less important than voting for how your
kids are raised exactly that was a very
big indicator so a very good point you
just made
on that part so real quick and maybe
christina can shed some light on this
last friday we had john stossel on right
and we spoke about ronda santa's banning
critical race theory and he brought up a
good point he's a libertarian that it is
that it is slightly it could be taken as
totalitarian you know you're banning
this you're saying it's not allowed from
the top down et cetera et cetera if you
put the shoe on the other foot it could
be done with something else against you
you know it's always a show on the other
foot test is it up to desantis to make
that call or should he be pushing the
parents to to pay more attention to the
school boards to elect the right people
like what you're seeing in loudoun
county i mean is it up to desantis to
make that call to ban it or should he
let it play out amongst the voters
two things one
first amendment rights which stossel was
referring to it doesn't apply to the
government schools are part of the
government as i said so like people
decide voters decide to elect
legislators legislators make laws
education is enshrined in the law like
what kids have to be taught in school we
do have standards in florida state
standards that are prescribed by the law
as i was saying african-american history
is one of them we have a law in
holocaust education that you have to
teach it as it's a fact not to say that
it's the theory or it's disputed or
anything like that that would be illegal
you would lose your job if you were a
teacher and you've said something like
that and so we have these laws for a
reason because again public education
it's a public good it's provided by the
government and so kids have the right to
learn facts and so
to say that teachers should have free
speech to say whatever they want in
class while they're government employees
it's like saying that i as a government
employee should be getting paid to
campaign against nikki freed or
something which is not allowed you know
like there are restrictions that you
have as a government employee you can
speak freely in your free time but you
can't while you're on the clock and
especially while you're teaching kids
you can't say whatever you want i mean
there was a teacher here in palm beach i
believe who said that the holocaust is a
theory and some people disagree that it
actually happened he was fired over it
not because he doesn't have free speech
rights but because he said it in class
to his students when he's a government
employee and you can't do that you're
not entitled to express your own opinion
in class if it's not um factual and if
it's not if there is a law about this
about what needs to be taught so that's
one thing the second thing is
discrimination is already against the
law if you're facing discrimination at
work for example from your employer if
you're facing discrimination
in university if you're a student and
you face racial discrimination or based
on gender or anything like that you have
the right to sue right and that's been
the law for a long time
um the types of things that are being
taught under the umbrella of critical
race theory
is discriminatory for example everyone
has probably heard the this kind of
hysterical example from coca-cola they
did a diversity training where they said
basically whiteness is bad try to be
less white as if you could change your
race and then they said whiteness like
meritocracy and competition it's forms
of whiteness now i don't believe that i
believe meritocracy means excellence and
anyone from any race can have that
quality it's not it's not tied to
whiteness it's not one specific race
that can only be so this type of thing
it is discrimination and that's been
against the law for a long time so i
don't i don't agree with stossel's
points at all for those two reasons and
i think libertarians i agree with them
on certain things but i think they don't
know what time it is now with the left
taking over so many institutions from
business to um schools we need to
conservatives should use their lawful
power
in order to ensure
that the facts are taught yeah
you know what my biggest challenge was
what stassel said about that
is
you can't he says well let the market
decide i said you can't move your kids
zip codes you're controlled when it's
statewide that's being taught let the
market decide on private school
that go forward open up a private school
and teach critical race theory 24 7
matter of fact i'd love a case study i
would love
for the democrats to fund opening up
schools that they teach heavy heavy race
theory in their private school and let's
see how many students pay how many
parents pay 30 grand a year for their
kids to go to that school i think it's a
great system if you think you're so
right and there's a market for it start
a school with the core foundation being
crt see if there's people that are
willing to pay money for it i think
that's a good idea public school is not
a marketplace of ideas and there are
some parts of this state where there's
no private schools so that that was my
challenge but what stassel said is he
can't say let the markets decide you
can't do that when i'm a taxpayer and
you create a law i can't compete a
market decide like it's a whole remember
parents used to get caught because they
wanted their kid to go to the better
public school and they gave them mom's
address and then they got caught and it
happens all the time happens all the
time i'm like dude this you can't do
that kind of stuff anyways okay let's go
to a couple other stories with the time
that we have here together so criticism
covet cases this morning i'm training
with my trainer okay
and he says who's on the podcast today i
said the press secretary uh pusha uh
governor desantis as press secretary he
says oh really i said yes i said let me
ask you for you what questions do you
have do you know who she says i don't
follow politics i said but what question
do you have for desantis he says well i
want to know how he's going to handle
this covet breakout on the state of
florida okay
now you got to realize there's people
that follow stories there's people that
follow headlines there's people that
kind of see what the news says and
that's it right with colby cases
can you pull up where florida ranks in
number of cases
uh a
number of cases for i don't know let's
do for
period ever go new kit and
new cases all time right there if you
can make it a little bit bigger so the
rest of us can see it okay florida what
is the number do they show the numbers
uh uh uh no you got to do
comparison go ranking go a little lower
there's a website right there go a
little lower a little lower a little
lower lower uh buy states
okay the one that says buy state
okay just go up forget about florida
just type in covet cases by state take
florida covet cases by state you got it
by state all right let's go there
go a little lower there should be a
ranking lower lower lower right there
click on that
and see where florida ranks lord is
going to be third because we're the
third biggest population i totally get
that and i want to i want to go to
what site would you say for him to go
can you help him out to see what side to
go to there's a website that shows all
of it a data tracker that's the one kova
data tracker
uh you just found it yeah go to kovid
covet data tracker
by state
yeah the cdc has a lot of information
here we go cdc go to
okay anyway so you're having a hard time
finding let me just ask you so the
questions would covet cases so the
criticism people get when i go to
california i'll go to new york i'll go
to greenwich i'll go to different
left
blue states right they'll say where are
you from florida oh my gosh how are
things there
oh my gosh it must be really bad over
there is it pretty bad with covet cases
i hear the hospitals are full i hear
it's just people are dying left and
right it's tragic what's going on
florida how are you protecting yourself
you would be amazed how many people have
an interpretation of what they think is
going on in florida so what would you
say about the handling of covet cases in
florida what are some data you can share
with the audience
i would say number one cases are not the
most serious metric to be focused on
because a lot of cases particularly
among people who were vaccinated or
people who are just in lower risk groups
the case might just be a positive test
you might not even be sick necessarily
or you might have like a slight cold or
something so what we've kind of focused
on more is preventing hospitalizations
so helping the most vulnerable people
who are actually vulnerable to severe
outcomes so if you look at the data i
mean i think the most important data
point to look at is deaths
over time since the beginning of the
pandemic
why because obviously
we want to save lives so new york's
death per capita
is higher than florida's despite the
fact that new york has so many
restrictions and florida does not and
our population is older than new york's
on average so we have a higher risk
population
for all states florida is i think number
17 or 18 in terms of number of deaths
which is a little bit higher than
average but again considering how old
our population is viewed just for the
age it's lower
and
considering the fact that so many of
those states that are higher than us in
deaths have these restrictions i think
it just goes to show you like there's no
real so that's a good chart there's no
real reason
um to say that these restrictions
actually worked and so i think that's
the thing i think when you're talking to
people from other states who have heard
this narrative in the media the media
has pushed it because they don't want
people to see that everything is fine in
florida and to see that we're actually
doing better than a lot of the
restrictive states and the mandate
states why because for whatever reason
media supports the restrictions more
okay go to war i just found it go to
world
okay i'm just going to send you this
link it's world on uh world ohmmeters
world that's a good one that's the one
if you go to world oh meters
and go down and make it a little bit
bigger so the audience can see keep
going down down down let's see if the
state shows up so when i'm looking at
i'm seeing the states there we go okay
so
uh buy cases go total cases
um make it bigger make it bigger make it
big okay so florida is number three okay
california's got seven point six seven
million
uh texas got six million cases floors
got five point three uh nine five so if
if that number is the way it is
florida should also be ranked third in a
number of people that have died due to
covets can you go to total
debts that we've had go to total bets
and let's see where it ranks there
it is yeah okay so it's third as well
it really should be total deaths by a
hundred thousand people
that's
per capita it's ranked 17th or 18th
we've been literally middle of the pack
the entire so so then here's a question
here's a question because
because that link i just sent you tyler
there's another good because if
if a nicki who's running for governor is
talking about how you know the santa's
running this place like a dictator okay
and you have newsome and you have cuomo
you have new york you have illinois who
everything's been mandate mandate
mandate
how is it that florida's you know number
of vets knowing this is a retirement
state this is where people come to
panama city to retire people come to
palm beach people come to places like
that yeah the villages so why do you
think what were some things desantis did
or the state of florida did where the
death per capita isn't third place where
the number of cases is third place in
for florida i mean it's a great question
i think number one all of these
restrictions that were trotted out like
from the lockdowns to the vaccine
mandates mask mandates none of that
stuff was proven to work this is the
first like we've had pandemics before in
our lifetimes the last one being h1n1 in
the 2000s and nobody ever talked about a
mask mandate like it just it wasn't on
the radar and so like
for whatever reason all these new things
were introduced in the last couple of
years with kovid but they haven't made a
difference now as far as what desantis
has actually done though he has focused
on well one he reads the research he
talks to different doctors like jay
bhattacharya from stanford martin
kuldorf from harvard like
doctors who who know their stuff but
they have a little bit of a different
perspective from the overarching
narrative and also if you know our
surgeon general dr joseph ladapo he just
recently joined from ucla um brilliant
guy harvard md phd and he has said the
same thing you know the restrictions
haven't worked we should be focusing on
overall health of the population and um
taking care of the people that actually
are vulnerable to serious outcomes
statistically that's older people so
governor desantis when the vaccines
became available prioritized seniors 65
and older the cdc was saying you should
prioritize front line workers but that
could be 20 year olds and he's like well
you know they're they're not at as much
risk and that's just a fact so we're
giving it to seniors cdc later updated
its guidelines next thing
he promoted treatments and still does
monoclonal antibody treatments saved
thousands of lives when the delta surge
was hitting florida very hard in summer
we really i think governor desantis
really pioneered that like opening all
the state treatment sites 25 sites
around the state where you can make an
appointment as soon as you test positive
go and get the treatment no prescription
needed and it kept a lot of folks out of
the hospital so they they would have had
to go to the hospital if they wouldn't
have gotten that outpatient treatment
but they they didn't have to be thanks
to this and so now other states are
doing it the binding administration has
not supported this they actually just
yesterday pulled two of the monoclonal
antibodies off the market without
showing us the data saying that they say
it's not effective against omicron but
they haven't shown us any data on that
so it's very weird but um but
yeah that's where the governor stood
apart i think that's why our death rate
is lower than many of these lockdown
states like new york for example or new
jersey or rhode island because we have
focused on protecting the vulnerable and
focused on treatment
how was how was governor desantis
relationship with anthony fauci
are they like did he go to dinner
together do they text each other do they
play scrabble i'm just curious
gotta be kidding so he
um
he has said that fauci has
been the most destructive influence on
our country during this
throughout the pandemic frankly and
actually about a week ago it's funny you
should ask a week ago his campaign
desantis's campaign released um they put
out merchandise all the time that you
can buy to support the game they
released a pair of flip-flops that are
fouchy flip-flops because he flip-flops
on so many things and then like he had
that's not a new thing flip-flops have
been out there i think uh george bush
almost got hit by a flip-flop at that
point yeah
but you can see them and so they're
pretty fun and then like earlier this
summer he had a beer koozie that said
don't fouchy my florida
so there you go so it says pound sand
falchi like so you could see
that um
i wouldn't say they have a good
relationship but why should they because
fauci has been fighting florida every
step of the way he's been he was against
reopening he was against opening beaches
and we know beaches are not dangerous in
terms of its spread let me let me ask
you if desantis was president today like
maybe you guys have had the discussion
he's a strong leader
how we how would he have handled fauci
you know he said something one of the
comments i'll read about what he said
about uh
uh he said it's on page six let me read
this to you and i'll go to the foundry
side where he said the
desantis regress not speaking out much
louder against trump's recommendation to
stay home this is a cnn story florida
governor desantis said one of the
biggest regrets in office was not
speaking out much later in march 2020
when uh former president donald trump
advised the nation to stay home to slow
the fast bread and corn over coronavirus
desantis blame people like anthony fauci
for advising trump to consider a
shutdown fauci the country's top
infectious disease expert was part of
the coronavirus response team that was
led by vice president mike pence and
included other public health experts but
the decision was trumps to make and
desantis ultimately followed the white
house lead closing florida schools
governing government buildings gyms bars
and restaurant dining rooms and advising
floridians to stay home so that's a
direct shot at trump and fauci but if if
governor desantis was the president
today if he was
how do you think he would have handled
falchi what what would that relationship
with voucher be would he have been fired
what would he have done with fouchy i'm
curious
well you know hindsight is always 20 20.
so if we were looking back at march 2020
april 2020 during the very beginning of
covid when nobody really knew what this
virus would do or we didn't have any
information about it of course a lot of
politicians governor desantis included
they
made policies out of an abundance of
caution i think but i think what
desantis has done
um which is unique for a politician to
do is he looked back on what happened in
april in the stay-at-home order for that
month and he said that was a mistake if
i had known then what i know now about
covid and about how it spreads and about
the risks i would not have issued that
order we would not have closed anything
no paul i mean it's so rare to hear a
politician just admit that and so
stannis has ruled out any future
lockdowns even when we had a case surge
recently it's going down now but we did
have a surge with omicron like every
state had um and you know that was never
on the radar the idea of closing things
as far as your question about fouchy in
particular well i want to back up the
interview that you're referring to where
trump where he mentioned um fauci and
you know cnn framed it as though it was
an attack on trump it wasn't he didn't
mention trump he mentioned
fauci by name and he clearly if you
listen to the context of that interview
on the ruthless podcast he clearly put
the blame on fauci for this idea that
lockdowns would work to control the
spread and um you know i think though
let's say
you know
one day governor desantis is president
and fauci is still around and again like
i said i don't know what he's going to
do but
he would be 83 i mean so you know i mean
he seems like he's
if desantis was president he would be
83. he seems like he's still um
he's still
pretty energetic and obviously has a
huge role in the biden administration a
very negative role but he has a lot of
power so seems to um you know as old as
he is still has
he's still sharp um i would say as a
civil servant you're limited in terms of
what you can do
in terms of firing civil servants but i
think there's a way to because fauci
lied to congress we know that like he
testified to congress something that
wasn't true
so that is a reason
a legal reason to remove him from his
position um if it were march 2020 before
all of that happened before the
congressional testimony before any of
this
and you see that fauci is
an activist and he screwed up i mean
earlier with the aids crisis when hiv
first started like he had a long history
of basically failures and so if you know
that and you want to sideline him you
can sideline him give him something to
do that has nothing to do with the
coveted response and work with people
like scott atlas j baracharya and these
different doctors who kind of are
looking at the evidence and have
different ideas you know and so i think
trump did when he was president he did
actually try to seek out those views but
he was really being
pushed from all sides whether from fauci
berks from the press from by from so
many people you know basically blaming
him unfairly i believe for all the kova
deaths that happened under his
presidency now we see biden biden's
presidency we've seen more people die
than died under trump nobody blames
biden directly for that and i don't
believe they should because i don't
believe that it's any president's fault
maybe the president of china i mean if
we want to blame somebody but like um
you know i so i think i wouldn't say
that anyone would get everything right
nobody's gotten everything right
throughout the entire pandemic but i do
think governor desantis's approach is to
look at the data see what it's showing
him and make a decision based off of
that
if um
question for you said hindsight is 20 20
i think we can all agree that you know
march of 20
you know march april that first initial
wave when we didn't know the hell was
going on people are wearing masks for
the first time ever
there's a different perspective now you
know hindsight is 20 20. um
so i think i'll just read you a quote
but it's basically
i'll just summarize it it's not just a
health crisis we're also dealing with an
economic crisis businesses shutting down
physical health crisis mental health
crisis we're talking about like that
like there's a famous
quote that war is too important to be
left to just the generals so essentially
you know this pandemic is too important
to be left to just the scientists the
fouchies of the world so you need
businessmen and operators and
entrepreneurs who are saying well yeah
i get it shutting down might you know
stop the spread but what happens to all
these businesses what happens to people
sitting at home you know not exercising
not getting out so i essentially
ultimately my question is
if you can summarize desantis's view of
how to handle covet in as few words as
possible
what would that be
keep people informed about the realities
about what the data says and let them
make their own decisions and respect
those i think you made a great point i
think
you know there was tunnel vision in this
country still is to some extent in some
places where people would just listen to
fauci or whichever of the doctors is on
cnn is saying that we need to do this
and that but they're not taking into
account the other effects about the
economy it's tied to health right if you
lose your job if you lose your business
your health deteriorates because of that
maybe not directly
it's chris it's mental health kids who
were locked out of school for a year and
a half are now in places like california
they're now seeing spikes in psychiatric
impatience treatment for kids which is
so sad because kids are not at high risk
um you know of the birth but they are at
high risk of depression they are at high
risk of suicide even like it's it's so
terrible that we didn't like a lot of
the
um scientific community mostly led by
fauci didn't really take this into
account they're focused on just covid
they don't think of the other health
risks um that are tied to the economy
that are tied to keeping things open and
living a normal life
and so i think it's all about balance
and governor desantis believes that as
well balancing
all these different concerns economic
and health wise to keep society
functioning and doing the least amount
of damage you know it's interesting
you're saying that because she just said
to business insider saki says biden
doesn't look at the stock market or to
judge how well the economy is doing
unlike trump that's what she said okay
so white house press secretary gen
zucker reacted to the drop by the u.s
stock market on monday saying president
biden doesn't solely rely on the stock
market two says how well the economy is
doing does the president think it's a
big deal that today's dow jones is down
at one point more than 1100 points
fox news reporter peter ducey asked saki
during a press briefing she responded on
the trends in the economy not any one
day and any single indicator
she then swiped that former president
trump's approach to the stock market
throughout his term trump would
regularly not
tout the performance of the stock market
often to credit whenever the market
experienced major gains unlike his pres
predecessor the president does not look
at the stock market as a means to judge
the economy i would not that the market
is up 15 compared to when the president
biden took office i would note that it's
up anyways i think uh you know what
people feel is a direct impact is the
economy that's what they feel the
average person feels the economy so i
think for somebody to say that if dow
hits 13 000 is he going to say yeah it's
that's not how you judge
you know how things are no i think the
average person's gonna like listen man i
just lost money yeah i just lost my
retirement uh you made you made another
point on what you were talking about i
want to kind of go through it in regards
to ukraine because that is a part where
you you have experience and haven't
worked in george and ukraine um a few
stories came out one of them is nato
ship so let's go through the one with
nato ships on page five uh nato sends
ships fighter jets to eastern europe as
russia tensions uh simmer this a
political story nato announced on monday
that european allies were deploying
added ships and fighter jets to eastern
europe and putting new forces on standby
in response to russia's continued
military mobilization along the
ukrainian border nato's announcement
comes amid reports that senior pentagon
officials on saturday presented u.s
president biden with options for
adopting a more aggressive posture
towards russia that would include
deploying additional military forces and
equipment to eastern europe while
ukraine is not an ally nato countries
have threatened severe sanctions in
response to any attack and secretary
general jens
stolzenberg has said that the alliance
will move quickly and forcefully to
protect its members including the small
baltic nations under article 5 the
collective defense clause and the nato
treaty how concerned are you with what's
going on over there right now i mean
it's obviously alarming and i would just
point out like
it's remarkable how
russia annexed part of ukraine crimean
peninsula under obama biden was vice
president he was the point guy on
ukraine he visited 17 times i think
during um his vice presidency then trump
gets into office then for four years
we didn't have any more incursions into
ukraine putin was not pushing i mean
they kept the crimea but they weren't
like trying to gain more ground
now suddenly a year after biden takes
office
putin is back and he is i mean by all
accounts like he is serious he does want
to make this um incursion whether it's
like a conventional invasion i don't
know but there are other things that can
be done that are acts of war like hybrid
war sending it like they did with crimea
like unmarked troops basically um cyber
attacks like different types of things
they can do to ukraine and so the
question is like why does the aggression
surge under
obama and biden but not
under trump you know and i think you
know one of those three presidents was
called a russian agent so i think it's
just absurd when you look at it the the
two presidents where russia has gained
power were both democrats right and like
um trump the one that they they made up
all these russia stories about
was was one where during his presidency
ukraine was in a safer position by far
than it is now now going to nato i mean
um
so nato it's interesting because what
trump said about nato when he was first
running for president was that they need
to pay their fair share there are a lot
of countries in nato that do not pay the
2 percent of the gdp towards defense
which is required
by the alliance and
he was right frankly we see germany for
example they don't pay that two percent
and they rely on russia for natural gas
for their population so it's like they
have a lot of dealings with russia that
makes them unable to or unwilling to
come to the defense of an ally ukraine
is not a nato ally though so like if
russia invades ukraine it doesn't
trigger that article 5 which is like
means collective defense that all the
nato allies have to come to their
defense it doesn't mean that nobody will
it just means it's not required
by the treaty
yeah another daily wire came out saying
biden slammed over reports he can't
evacuate u.s citizens out of ukraine
criminally incompetent news reports
indicate that the bible administration
has ordered families of all american
personnel u.s embassy in ukraine to
immediately leave the country he's
warned u.s citizen the country that will
be unable to evacuate and it's
considering sending us military forces
to eastern europe given that the
president has said military actions by
russia could come out at any time the
u.s government will not be in position
to evacuate u.s citizens biden state
department said so and so u.s citizens
currently present any in ukraine should
plan
accordingly
what does this really mean because the
continue to say monica crowley former
trump official says biden here is still
cool with abandoning americans and war
zones holy crap it's august all over
again i mean frankly that was my first
reaction when i saw this too because we
all remember what happened in
afghanistan this horrible tragedy that
happened a few months ago in summer
when americans were stranded when
hundreds i mean we don't even know how
many afghans civilians were killed at
that airport bombing we lost 13 american
service members at that bombing and so
these images and what we saw there
during this botched and just horrific
withdrawal from afghanistan that was
botched in every way um this is all it's
fresh in our minds so when we hear the
same types of rhetoric coming out like
that americans need to leave you can
arrange your own transportation out of
ukraine that does bring back deja vu it
brings back that very traumatic memory
recently of what happened in afghanistan
and you know i i truly hope like ukraine
is different from afghanistan i truly
hope we don't see a repeat um of what we
saw over there
but it is worrisome that it seems like
biden has left putin in the driver's
seat like it's up to russia whether they
invade or not we're
we just want to get out like no it
should be if if we want to be a world
power we should say we're not going to
tolerate you don't think putin is
intimidated by biden i i don't believe
so you don't think so i mean why would
he be if he were intimidated by biden he
wouldn't be he wouldn't be doing what
he's doing today i mean he sounds like a
pretty intimidating guy what he said to
peter ducey yesterday right the question
was asked did you hear what he said to
peter ducey if you want to pull that up
uh matter of fact just play it david if
you can turn it over so we can show the
video
uh when peter ducey asked the question
if he can make that bigger somehow
control plus and then audio would be
very helpful tyler most people can't
yeah go back to this
political liability ahead of the
midterms
that's a great asset
more inflation
what a stupid sound a little bit
so how bad is that by the way is that is
that like an atom to you you hear that
does that do anything to you or you're
like i can't believe he said that that's
not a pro or a con to me i mean it's
like okay good for you got it i mean
trump has said worse on a hot mic loudly
so
this is the thing though you know you
voted for biden a lot of people who
voted for biden i'm not making
assumptions about your reasons but a lot
of people said it's because trump's not
civil enough he doesn't act presidential
he says stuff like that and so when
biden says the same thing
you know i think
it should be condemned the same way but
it's not really me if he had a track
record of doing that to reporters and
calling the you know media fake news and
literally encouraging people to fight
each other yeah okay yes let's
on on biden he kind of was like
i mean who doesn't talk like that ever i
mean i mean if someone pisses you off
okay if someone pisses you off like
regardless of who you are
but you know what would happen if let's
say if governor desantis he has a press
conference today and if he said
something like that to a reporter the
media would go insane like you might not
i'm not saying you would but but but you
know it would be like a nuclear meltdown
from cnn and from you know i hear what
you're saying
you know fool me once you know shame on
you if only twice if this starts to
being a reoccurring theme that biden has
just just found it happened last week as
well yeah but most of the time he's
calling you like a foul-mouthed pony
face dog like
let me ask you who seems uh uh that
they're angrier trump or biden
right now no no no just period who's go
to go to trump and then they would ask
him questions no no was he angry was he
competitive was he a troll because biden
just seems angry
i i will give you that yeah he seems
angry he seems like he's bitter i'm like
buddy nobody was fighting i think trump
is in a whole another atmosphere but
clearly
biden's poll numbers are
in the gutter yeah he's not exactly
having a great week or a great month or
a great way to start the year
so he's a little feisty you know what
i'd show a little backbone and call
somebody a son of a [ __ ] i'm okay with
that uh sleepy joke yeah wake up i will
i will tell you what happened yesterday
right afterwards so peter ducey goes on
fox and he tells him how it was and what
happened because he didn't know what he
said back to him he couldn't hear him he
thought he said sob says no they said
the whole thing and then you know
they're talking about that would be a
great title for a book you know stupid
son of a can you imagine a title for a
book that'd be a great title for book
but he says later on biden called them
biden called him and he says nothing
yeah he says i just got a call from
biden on my cell
and he said hey nothing personal pal
that's what he said he said nothing i do
too i like that to be honest with you
the fact that he called doctor
and
he said nothing personal and then he
said afterwards he said uh president
biden you just have to know i'm going to
ask the questions that others are not
willing to ask you and biden said and
you should yeah so credit to biden for
actually do you do when biden loves
america
a a
different kind of america not the same
america that uh
maybe you love not the same america that
i love i don't think he loves what type
of america do you think biden likes i
think of the there is
look she said something very important
at the beginning she said the reason why
it's easy for me to represent um um
scientists is because i agree on
everything he talks about that's not
easy to do by the way right i mean you
have to know you represent somebody like
oh if i agree with what you said right
let me tell you what president trump was
really trying to secretary yeah exactly
so it's challenging to be a press
secretary for somebody like trump
because trump is very what
unpredictable right where desantis is
very predictable right do i sit there
and think he loves uh
america
i don't i don't know if he loves america
i think he's so you don't think biden
loves america i don't think biden loves
the freedom of speech i don't think
biden loves you having the choice to do
what you want to do
in every possible way i think biden
loves democrats i don't think biden
loves america this is why i asked a
question from her
on
who does desantis love more florida or
america that's a pointed question
because if you love america america kind
of needs a president like him where he's
calm collected family guy go run do your
thing and go back to your family spend
time with your wife and kids i think
he's more his political party
over
america which is
left and right i think desantis is more
for
those who believe in what america was
founded on freedom leave me alone a
little bit of a
free enterprise free market capitalism i
think you can make a decision for
yourself where i think he thinks the
government can make better decisions for
you than you can make for yourself
that's what i mean that his america is a
different america than mine you're
saying you're saying he believes in
america but with a little bit more uh
government uh overreach like like it's
saying does that does that parent love
his kids i think he loves his kids
but his method of
raising his kids is too much control i
don't believe he's so much of a micro
manager
i i don't think he has any idea what's
going on today i just think he thinks he
knows what's best for you over you know
what's best christina do you have strong
feelings on this do you think biden
loves america do you think he's in his
right mind doing the best job you can do
for america what are your thoughts
i mean to be honest he's been in
politics for 50 years right i mean so
he's been in washington dc
in that bubble and it really is a bubble
you know when you're an elected official
there in congress in the senate and the
vice president and he's just been in
this world that most americans do not
live in it's a very different world and
i think he he believes he's doing the
right things i think he believes that he
he loves america but he doesn't love
the individual liberties aspect that our
country was founded on i don't think i i
tend to agree that um
that he
believes big government is the solution
to everything and perhaps that's because
he's been in government for his whole
career i mean like look when you've been
in washington dc and that's been your
entire life and he hasn't owned a
business you know like he hasn't um
dealt with the same types of things that
american families deal with every day he
just has a different kind of life um
then that's maybe why his perspective is
is so different um from somebody who
let's say who was a business owner
before like trump or somebody who comes
from a more middle class or
working-class background like desantis
and just knows what like lives in a
different state and knows what people in
our state are dealing with so yeah i
don't know why so do you think he loves
america
yeah i do think he loves america do you
think trump loves america i do think
trump loves america do you think i think
i think do you think bernie sanders
loves america
i think uh
i do think bernie sanders loves america
less than those two you think aoc loves
america i do i just think she's got a
different interpretation so we're saying
the same thing so that's exactly what
we're saying yeah you can you can love
the country but have a different vision
no no no then no no that's not how this
thing works but
you're you're systemically wanting this
great country to change you systemically
don't you don't like what the foundation
of what this country was like well do
you think fdr loved america
do i because he got a lot of heat after
the new deal about social security and
medicare and medicaid and big government
but now everyone loves that yeah no no i
everybody loves what i mean those
systems i you doubt any seniors or old
people or sick people are trying to
not have social security wait a minute
wait a minute okay i'm just putting a
difference now you're you're going into
a different direction give the whole
story into context because first of all
when he came out with social security do
you know how many people use social
security the first year when he came out
with social security well there weren't
that many old people at that point
that's the point so it wasn't a big deal
so there's no doubt social security is
i'm not saying no 50 social security
kicks in at 62. people are living
fdr isn't as bad as the right painting
out to be and isn't as great as the left
paints them out to be so to me fdr a lot
of like oh my gosh they say bad things
about fdn you're looking he raised
minimum wage one time i think obama
raised minimum wage four times he raised
and obama only raised it one time do you
know who raised minimum wage the most
time like he raised it to 25 cents he
just had 25 cents what the minimum wage
ought to be and he you know kind of went
after four because ford was essentially
having their average employee working 70
hours a week i think that's also a
little bit of use by not choice that's
w-2 not 10.99 it's not sales but i will
tell you this in regards to
biden when when you're in a bubble for
too long
i run sales organizations you know what
i do so
i'll talk to my sales leaders and a
sales leader will ask me and say hey pat
man how do you deal with these guys that
are just making 15 bucks an hour man
you're trying to get these guys to
realize you got to work hard you got to
have your dreams become a reality
man why do people have such bad i just
have a hard time talking to these people
sometimes
it's a very big red flag
very very big red flag why
the moment you lose the ability to
understand what you were like when you
sucked at one point
you lose
the vote
the moment you forget about the pains of
what it was to be broke you lose the
vote the moment you forget about what it
is to be a small business owner if
you've never experienced it dude i
understand the pain of a small business
owner i understand the pain of a kid
that's coming up that wants to do
something with their lives and they got
bad habits i understand what it is to be
in a bubble of nightclubs and you're
stuck in it and you just can't wait to
leave it because but at the same time
i'm like dude but i miss that nightlife
it's a bubble we everybody if you get
too caught up in the bubble that you're
in you're blindsided by reality we all
will go through it i just think he's in
a state where
he's so blindsided i don't know how many
core
to the core beliefs he has that he's
presenting i think it's a lot of me too
core beliefs i think aoc has core
beliefs i think sanders has core beliefs
i think trump has core beliefs i think
obama has core beliefs i think those
guys the santa's core beliefs trump core
beliefs i i don't see a desantis as core
beliefs i mean biden i i don't i'm sorry
my apologies i don't see biden as
corporal she's about to jump out of her
no no i don't see i don't see biden's
core beliefs i think he's been in it for
so long that he's just kind of like yeah
uh i'm a democrat we should do this
oh you guys are changing yeah we should
do i think it's too much about
you know the whole flip-flopping thing
no you got to have a backbone you got to
stand up and you got to get some people
to get upset about your saying hey
here's what i believe this is what we
need to do this is what it was founded
on so yeah i think he loves a different
america anyways um
really enjoyed having you on okay
likewise yeah it was a great
conversation really enjoyed having you
on uh i have one last question for
christina if it's okay here we go you
know i went to school
at florida state i lived in tallahassee
for four years how are you liking
tallahassee and it's a big difference
from from la in washington d.c totally
different it's a culture shock i mean
when i came down there i didn't have a
car i hadn't driven in dc in four years
because like you don't need it there
yeah so i came down and i'm like oh my
gosh what am i gonna do like i
immediately that's like the first thing
i ran out got a license it took me a
while to get it i got a license
i didn't even have a license
because i mean i did from california but
it was expired so i went and i got that
and then it took me months to find a car
because of the shortages and all of this
stuff and so that was kind of my
introduction but now i feel like i've
come to appreciate tallahassee more
number one because we have an awesome
team at the governor's office like i
love my co-workers we have a lot of fun
and they're all good people like they're
all mission driven meaning like it's not
most political jobs it's kind of a lot
of personalities competing with each
other but with our team it's it's like
we're all working for the bigger goal we
have a bigger vision in mind so like
that helps a lot it's it's a very unique
kind of situation there and i think it
really reflects on desantis as a good
leader um and then the other thing is
you know
exploring that part of florida um even
though tallahassee might not be much to
look at there are some beautiful parts
of florida like a short drive away you
can do a day trip into like the
panhandle
yeah and i never knew much about that
part of the state i've been to miami
before like a lot of people from dc go
on vacation to miami like aoc um so i i
knew south florida a little bit more do
me a favor yeah next time you go out in
tallahassee i assume sometimes you go
out and have a good time sometimes you
do maybe you go to this place called
potbellies it's a nice time you have a
good time but the next time you know
about that
okay so here's my request
there's a restaurant called guthrie's
you ever heard of it no you get one of
these gut boxes they're amazing it has
like this sauce
that it's like addictive next time you
come down to here to south florida you
get some guthries you bring it down
you'll thank me later okay all right
i'll remember that guthrie's by the way
i officially know for a fact you're his
hero when you said you haven't driven
for four years because adam ten years
you know uh we've sent uh uh i don't
know how many emails we've sent to the
governor de santa's office if you
received it or not to revoke his
driver's license
florida is safer without him driving
you're listening
please revoke his license we're begging
you it is a uh extreme catastrophic
situation here and if governor desantis
is ever in south florida to fort
lauderdale we'd love to host him on the
podcast if he's ever in fort lauderdale
have a conversation with them but having
said that thank you for coming out thank
you appreciate you folks we will do this
again i believe on thursday we don't
have oh shoot we do not have we have you
have a small event coming up on we have
a small event sls at miami a sales
leadership seminar for those of you guys
that are in that space
and you want to attend it i think we got
to handle it's a small event we don't do
a default big event
if you want to have somebody reach out
to you and you're a sales leader doing
over a million dollars you have to be
qualified to go to this send us a
message we'll have one of our guys
contact you maybe put the link below for
people to be able to find having said
that
we will do podcasts again is it next
tuesday time tuesday so we're off the
entire week this week
we're going to be in miami
we'll miss you because we did three
times last week it's true once this week
we'll see you next tuesday take care
everybody have a great weekend bye
you